danke ja
[Applaus]
liebe liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde etwas Neues zu beginnen das
Gesicht ganz vorne in den Wind zu halten
das erfordert Mut und ich denke wir
kennen sie alle die Zweifel vor dem
richtigen Weg die Frage wir werden
Freunde Bekannte auf diesen Schritt
reagieren und auch die Sorge ob wir die
riesige Aufgabe die jetzt vor uns steht
ob wir die wirklich bewältigen oder ob
sie uns vielleicht auch
überfordert ihr habt die Entscheidung
getroffen deshalb seid ihr heute hier
als erstmitglieder des Bündnisses SAR
Wagenknecht dass es ohne euch nicht
geben würde und darüber freue ich mich
und ich danke euch dass ihr den Mut
dafür aufgebracht
habt wir machen uns
jetzt wir machen uns jetzt gemeinsam auf
den Weg die Politik in Deutschland zu
verändern und wir tun das weil wir
spüren da ist etwas am kippen in uns
Gesellschaft es gibt so viele Probleme
so viel Unsicherheit aber auch so viel
Empörung und Wut die Politik des
Aussitzens und wegmoderierens der
kleinen Kompromisse und der großen
Ignoranz die wird wahrscheinlich so
nicht weitergehen aber die Frage ist was
kommt dann mündet der Umbruch in einen
Aufbruch oder in die Katastrophe alles
ist möglich und wir starten auch jetzt
deshalb weil wir nicht nur zuschauen
sondern weil wir eingreifen und handeln
wollen weil ab jetzt hängt es auch von
uns ab wie Deutschland in 5 oder 10
Jahren aussehen wird und ich denke das
ist ganz wichtig und es ist toll dass
ihr dabei
seid
liebe liebe Freundinnen und Freunde uns
ein die gemeinsame Sorge um die Zukunft
uns einen die programmatischen Ziele die
in unserem Programm formuliert sind aber
wir sind auch sehr
verschieden viele von uns haben sich
über viele Jahre in der Linken engagiert
andere kommen aus anderen Parteien und
wieder andere haben sich zum ersten Mal
in ihrem Leben entschieden politisch
aktiv zu werden unter uns sind
Gewerkschafter Betriebsräte und
erfolgreiche Unternehmer Krankenpfleger
und Polizisten Theologen und Atheisten
Großstädter und Dorfbewohner in einem
Land das sich immer mehr in Lager
spaltet ind dem die einzelnen Milieus
sich immer seltener begegnen ist das
keine
Selbstverständlichkeit sondern etwas
ganz besonderes und wertvolles und wir
werden auch nur erfolgreich sein wenn
wir diese unsere Unterschiedlichkeit als
Gewinn begreifen wenn wir Toleranz und
Respekt nicht nur in der Gesellschaft
einfordern sondern auch hier in unserer
Partei Leben das muss unser Auftrag und
das muss unser Ziel
sein
liebe liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir
sind keine linke 20 und das muss auch
für unseren Umgang miteinander gelten
lasst uns eine Partei des Miteinanders
werden und nicht eine Partei der
Intrigen und des postengeschachers wie
alle
anderen und lasst uns Strukturen
schaffen in denen sich nicht die
rücksichtslosesten und intrigantesten
durchsetzen sondern die talentiertesten
und besten denn das wollen wir auch in
der Gesellschaft und dann fangen wir bei
uns an das ist ganz wichtig und das wird
uns von allen anderen unterscheiden wenn
wir so
sind und deshalb bitte ich
euch lasst uns pfleglich miteinander
umgehen ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig
dass wir das zu unserem Credo machen es
ist unsere Verantwortung die großen
Erwartungen die Hoffnungen die jetzt
ganz viele Menschen auf uns setzen die
wir täglich erleben wenn uns Menschen
ansprechen auf der Straße im
Supermarkt lasst uns diese Hoffnungen
diese Erwartungen nicht enttäuschen das
ist unsere große Verantwortung die wir
alle gemeinsam jetzt tragen müssen und
unser Land es braucht unbedingt einen
politischen Neubeginn für
wirtschaftliche Vernunft statt
Klientelpolitik für soziale
Gerechtigkeit statt einer immer
wachsenden Ungerechtigkeit und
Ungleichheit für Frieden für Entspannung
statt neuer
hochrüungswettläufe und immer mehr Krieg
und ja auch für Meinungsfreiheit und
Respekt gegenüber dem Andersdenkenden
statt kcel culture und einem
übergriffigen politischen Autoritarismus
den wir in der coronazeit in seiner
krassesten Form erlebt haben aber der ja
heute auch nicht weg ist sondern der das
Meinungsspektrum immer weiter verengt
und das machen wir nicht mit das wollen
wir verändern und es ist wichtig dass
sich das
[Applaus]
ändert
immer mehr Menschen immer mehr Menschen
in unserem Land sind politisch heimatlos
geworden weil sie statt vernünftiger
Entscheidungen eine Politik erleben die
keinen Plan und keine Antworten hat eine
Politik die sich nur noch in ihrer Blase
bewegt und die Probleme die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
jeden Tag erleben die diese Probleme
nicht nur nicht löst sondern offenkundig
zum Teil noch nicht einmal kennt Amira
hat ja das Beispiel vorhin genannt der
VF von Ricarda lang immerhin
Vorsitzender einer Regierungspartei bei
der Abschätzung der deutschen
durchschnittsrent das ist doch das
Sinnbild dieser Abgehobenheit wie soll
jemand eine vernünftige Rentenpolitik
machen der noch nicht einmal weiß welche
Probleme die Millionen Rentnerinnen und
Rentner in unserem Land überhaupt haben
das ist doch
absurd
und vermutlich vermutlich denkt Robert
habck auch alle Menschen in Deutschland
leben in modernen
Niedrigenergiehäusern oder in den
schönen topsanierten altbaulofts wie
seine grünen Freunde in den
hochpreisigen großstadtquartieren und
deshalb hielt er das für eine geniale
Idee ganz Deutschland eine Wärmepumpe
für den Heizungskeller zu verordnen so
läuft Politik heute aber genau deswegen
wenden sich eben immer mehr Menschen ab
oder der frühere Blackrock Lobbyist
Friedrich merärz der im Privatflieger
durch die Welt düst und ernsthaft glaubt
so lebt die deutsche Mittelschicht was
ist daran noch irgendwie Bürger nah oder
geerdet das ist doch völlig absurd was
diese Leute
machen
und
und vom höfeesterben hat die ganze
ampelriegel Riege offenbar auch noch nie
irgendwas gehört davon dass allein in
den letzten 10 Jahren 40.000
Landwirtschaftsbetriebe in Deutschland
aufgeben mussten weil sie dem
Doppeldruck nicht mehr standhalten
konnten der auf der einen Seite von
mächtigen Supermarktketten und großen
Lebensmittelkonzern ausgeübt wird und
auf der anderen Seite von billig
Importen die die Politik Organ hat und
mit immer neuen Freihandelsabkommen wie
mit dem merkosur immer weiter
organisiert offenbar haben die das
überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm was die
Landwirte in Deutschland für Probleme
haben und deswegen frage ich mich in
welchem Paralleluniversum müssen
Politiker leben die ausgerechnet dieser
Branche jetzt die Stopfen ihrer
Haushaltslöcher auferlegt das ist eine
völlig falsche Politik und wir sagen
ganz klar nein diese Belastungen die
müssen komplett zurückgenommen werden
die Belastungen für die Landwirte die
weil so kann es auf keinen Fall
weitergehen und wenn dann den Bauern
wenn dann den Bauern die Hutschnur
platzt und sie ihren Protest
unüberhörbar auf die Straße tragen ja
dann heißt es plötzlich uh Pui das ist
ja von rechts über unterwandert weil man
irgendwo neben einem Traktor oder hinter
einem Misthaufen doch im Ernst einen
rechtsradikalen gesichtet hat es ist
tatsächlich das gleiche wie letztes Jahr
Amira hat es schon gesagt als 50.000
Menschen vor dem Brandenburger Tor für
Frieden in der Ukraine demonstriert
haben und von Medien und Politik als
Putin nah aber eben auch als rechtsoffen
und AFD nah defamiert wurden so darf es
doch nicht weitergehen mit den Debatten
in unserem
Land
weil ein Ergebnis ein Ergebnis dieser
irren Debatte ist ja tatsächlich dass
die AFD heute als Friedenspartei gilt
eine Partei die den aktuellen
rekordrüstungsetat von 85 Milliarden
Euro eher noch zu klein findet und deren
verteidigungspolitischer Sprecher das
wissen leider die wenigsten mit der
Rüstungsindustrie Wirtschaft
verbandelt ist und deswegen um keinen
Deut besser ist als die
rüstungslobbyistin Marie Agnes Strack
reinmetall das ist doch alles eine Suppe
das ist doch alles völlig
falsch aber das sind die Diskussionen
das sind die verrückten Diskussion die
wir in unserem Land teilweise führen das
Werben für Frieden rechts die verte ung
der Bauernhöfe rechts die Kritik an
Schulschließungen und Konformitätsdruck
in der coronazeit rechts die Forderung
nach Begrenzung der Zuwanderung und die
Sorge vor islamistischen
Parallelgesellschaften rechts und
nachdem man den Leuten jahrelang
eingehämmert hat dass alles vernünftige
Recht sei ja dann wundert man sich wenn
am Ende eine tatsächlich rechte Partei
eine Partei die Rechtsextremisten und
Nazis in ihren Reihen hat wenn die am
Ende aus so einer Debatte als Sieger
hervorgeht jetzt bei über 20% steht und
im Osten auf die absolute Mehrheit hofft
ja das ist doch nicht erstaunlich aber
es ist nicht das Ergebnis einer
besonders genialen Politik in der AFD
zentrale sondern es ist das Ergebnis der
falschen Politik im Berliner
Regierungsbezirk das muss man noch immer
wieder ganz deutlich
sagen
und Frederik Frederik hat es vorhin
schon angesprochen jetzt gehen also die
ampelpolitiker selbst auf die Straße und
demonstrieren heldenhaft gegen die
Ergebnisse ihrer eigenen Politik was ist
das für eine Heuchelei und
Scheinheiligkeit und man muss
man muss ganz klar sagen wenn Sie die
AFD wirklich Schwächen wollen ja bitte
schön da müssen sie nicht demonstrieren
dann müssen sie endlich mal ihre
miserable Politik verändern sie haben es
doch in der Hand dann machen sie es doch
endlich mal so kann es doch nicht
weitergehen wie es jetzt
läuft und
ja ja natürlich ja natlich sich auch
viele viele Menschen an den
Demonstrationen weil sie ehrlich Angst
haben vor dem erstärken der AFD und sie
haben auch recht damit diese Angst habe
ich auch und ich glaube wir alle hier
die wir hier im Saal sitzen aber man
muss natürlich auch sagen wer die AFD
wirklich Schwächen will der sollte auch
für politische Forderungen demonstrieren
er sollte auch z.B für einen höheren
Mindestlohn von wenigstens 14 €
demonstrieren weil der überfällig ist in
unserem Land er sollte für bessere
Renten demonstrieren für ein
Rentensystem wie in Österreich wo die
Durchschnittsrente ja tatsächlich bei
2000 € liegt Liebe ricarder lang das
könnten wir hier haben da müssen Sie
sich nur mal in Österreich das abgucken
was man dafür machen
muss und wer die AFD Schwächen will ja
er sollte auch für bezahlbare Energie
demonstrieren und gegen
Wirtschaftssanktionen die nicht Russland
sondern die deutsche Wirtschaft
ruinieren er sollte demonstrieren für
ein mietendeckel und für Krankenhäuser
ohne Renditedruck er sollte
demonstrieren für Frieden für ein Ende
der Hochrüstung und am besten gleich für
Neuwahlen und ein Ende der unsäglichen
Ampel das alles fordert das BSW dafür
sind wir angetreten und dafür bräuchten
wir eigentlich
Massendemonstrationen
denn wir dürfen natürlich auch nicht
vergessen auch wenn die Ampel sich ihren
Titel als dümmste Regierung Europas
jeden Tag aufs Neue verdient weil sie
unser Land in die Krise und
schlimmstenfalls sogar in einen Krieg
führt es geht um mehr als um die
Ablösung einer unfähigen Regierung ein
Friedrich märz im Kanzleramt der der die
Rente noch weiter kürzen und
taurusraketen an die Ukraine liefern
will damit selenski demnächst mit
deutschen Waffen sogar Moskau angreifen
kann ein solcher Friedrich märz im
Kanzleramt wäre ganz sicher nicht das
kleinere
Übel und
viele und viele Fehlentwicklungen den
Folgen wir heute spüren die haben auch
lange begonnen bevor das Trio infernaler
aus habeg berburg und Lindner unter
einem sprachlosen Kanzler mit lediertem
Erinnerungsvermögen die Geschäfte in
Deutschland übernommen hat das geht doch
viel viel weiter zurück ja es läuft
nicht gut in unserem Land das spüren die
Menschen und Veränderung beginnt auch
damit dass die wichtigen Fragen endlich
einmal wieder ins Zentrum der
Aufmerksamkeit Rücken auch da dafür
haben wir uns gegründet denn die Politik
und auch das debattenklima in unserem
Land sind roh geworden voller Verachtung
gegenüber denen die ganz unten stehen
und da sind sich wieder alle von der
Ampel bis zur AFD erschreckend
einig natürlich verstehe ich dass
diejenigen die jeden Morgen aufstehen
und hart arbeiten oder auch diejenigen
die für ihren Handwerksbetrieb ihr
Kaffee oder Ihre Bäckerei Händeringen
Personal suchen und keines finden dass
sie empört sind wenn andere sich im
Modell Bürgergeld plus Schwarzarbeit
eingerichtet haben das ist ein Problem
aber ein Problem haben wir auch wenn in
einem Land in dem die einzige noch
richtig schnell wachsende Branche die
Tafeln sind die mittlerweile über 2
Millionen Bedürftige versorgen wenn in
einem solchen Land nur noch über
Sozialmissbrauch
und nicht mehr über Armut geredet wird
das ist doch ein wirklich gravierendes
[Applaus]
Problem
wenn wenn nicht mehr geredet wird über
den
61jährigen gerüstebauer der sich seine
Knochen kaputt gearbeitet hat und
einfach in seinem Job nicht mehr
arbeiten kann und dann gnadenlos nach 2
Jahren Arbeitslosigkeit in die Armut
stürzt wenn nicht mehr geredet wird über
die alleinerziehende Mutter die schon
deshalb kein Jobangebot annehmen kann
weil die Politik bis heute es nicht
geschafft hat flächendecken für
ganztagskiterplätze zu sorgen und wir
alle kennen ja die Debatte wir alle
kennen die Debatte über die angeblich
mangelnde Bereitschaft jüngerer sich
anzustrengen und die Debatte über mehr
Druck der da nötig wäre aber vielleicht
sollten wir auch mal über Motivation
reden die Bundesrepublik ist ein mit dem
Slogan Wohlstand für alle gestartet
jeder der sich anstrengt sollte
Aufstiegschancen und die Aussicht auf
ein gutes Leben haben diese
Aufstiegschancen die gibt es doch fast
gar nicht mehr wer arm geboren ist der
bleibt fast immer Arm das ist die
Realität und dann wundert man sich wenn
junge Menschen die schon in ihrer
Kindheit immer nur verzichten mussten
die in maroden runtergekommenen Schulen
lernen mussten und die ein
Bildungssystem erlebt haben das noch
nicht mal in der Lage war ihnen halbwegs
korrekt Lesen Schreiben und Rechnen
beizubringen wenn diese jungen Menschen
mit wenig oder gar keiner Motivation ins
Leben starten ja das ist doch gar nicht
verwunderlich das liegt doch in dieser
Ausgangslage begründet und deswegen muss
man diese Ausgangslage verändern und
verbessern und auch dafür treten wir
[Applaus]
an und was gar nicht geht was gar nicht
geht wenn dann verwöhnte Jungpolitiker
kommen die trotz besserer stschancen es
oft auch nicht haben wenigstens einen
soliden Abschluss zu machen und die
jetzt schon
wieder und die jetzt schon wieder und
das finde ich besonders perfide das Geld
für die Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung
von Arbeitslosen kürzen wenn diese
Jungpolitiker uns dann den Wert von
Fleiß und Anstrengung erklären also das
ist doch wirklich ein hohen auch
gegenüber den Betroffenen aber auch
gegenüber uns allen
[Applaus]
dieselben dieselben Politiker übrigens
die sich als hochmoralische Gutmenschen
inszenieren die angeblich mit jedem im
Käfig gehaltenen Huhn und mit jeder
Kröte am Straßenrand leiden aber die ist
wenn es darauf ankommt die nicht davor
zurückschrecken frierenden Familien
schon wieder die Heizkosten zu erhöhen
oder den schon seit der coronazeit
strauchelnden gastw in die Pleite zu
stürzen das ist doch die Doppelmoral die
wir überall erleben und das geht so
nicht weiter
Politiker Politiker den es sowas von
egal ist wenn auf dem Land kein Bus mehr
fährt oder auch noch die letzte
Arztpraxis schließt aber die sich dann
hochmoralisch über alte weiße Männer
muckieren mit überholten Autos und
überholten
Ernährungsgewohnheiten das ist doch die
Diskrepanz zwischen dem aufgeblasenen
Moralismus dieser angeblichen
fortschrittskoalition und einer in der
Realität zutiefst amoralischen und
reaktionären Politik das treibt die
Leute um und das treibt sie den falschen
in die Arme das wollen wir dringend
verändern und ja wir brauchen
Anstrengungen für eine
umweltverträgliche und klimaneutrale
Wirtschaft aber wir brauchen durchdachte
Lösungen und deswegen freue ich mich
auch dass wir so viel Kompetenz in
unseren reinhaben auch bei dieser Frage
wir brauchen durchdachte Lösungen und
nicht eine Regierung die Milliarden
dafür investiert von dem relativ
umweltfreundlichen und klimafreundlichen
Pipeline Gas auf das extrem Klima und
umweltfeindliche freckinggas umzusteigen
dass dann noch mit Schiffen über die
halbe Welt transportiert wird und die
gleichzeitig es für eine gute Idee hält
russisches Öl in Zukunft möglichst CO2
intensiv und teuer über Indien zu
importieren weil wir ja die guten sind
was ist das für eine verrückte Politik
das ist keine Klimapolitik das ist das
[Applaus]
Gegenteil eine Regierung die mit höheren
CO2 Preisen ihre Haushaltslöcher stopft
und gleichzeitig alles dafür tut dass
die barodebahn bloß keine gute und
irgendwie akzeptable Alternative wird
eine Regierung die zuschaut wie
Zukunftstechnologien die wir für die
Klimawende dringend brauchen wie die aus
unserem Land abwandern während sie
gleichzeitig den Aktionären eines
amerikanischen
halbleiterkonzerns der seine
innovativste Zeit längst hinter sich hat
10 Milliarden in den Rachen wirft wer
soll so eine Regierung noch irgendetwas
[Applaus]
glauben und ja wir müssen wieder reden
wir müssen wieder reden über
gesellschaftliche Ungleichheit weil das
tut keiner über uns über die Enteignung
der fleißigen seit di Jahren sinken die
Kaufkraft der Löhne in Deutschland und
in vielen Branchen sinkt sie schon
wesentlich länger es gibt immer mehr
Berufe die früher einen bescheidenen
Wohlstand ermöglicht haben und in denen
die Einkommen heute so sind dass man mit
ihnen nie die Chance auf ein halbwegs
gutes Leben hat auf ein Mindestmaß an
sozialer Sicherheit auf eine solide
Familienplanung oder gar auf ein eigenes
Häuschen oder eine eigene Wohnung und
das muss sich doch wieder ändern in
unserem Land und wir müssen reden über
eine gespaltene Wirtschaft wo der
Mittelstand immer mehr unter Druck gerät
aber gleichzeitig auch das gehört ja
dazu die 40 größten Unternehmen in
Deutschland in diesem Jahr mitten in der
Krise mehr Dividenden ausschütten als je
zuvor das ist doch völlig absurd eine
solche
Entwicklung und
deshalb deshalb fordern wir deshalb
fordern wir schärfere kartellgesetze
auch gegen die Macht der Datenkraken aus
überse und den Abbau der ganzen
aberwitzigen Vorschriften und Auflagen
die eine St wachsende beraterindustrie
nähren und in den kleinen und mittleren
Betrieben völlig sinnlos Kapazitäten
binden auch das muss ich ändern und wir
müssen darüber reden dass es kein Zufall
ist dass der Mix aus Steuersenkungen und
Steuererhöhungen den die ampelt den
Bürgern in diesem Jahr zu Beginn des
Jahres offeriert hat dass der wieder mal
die ärmeren und die untere Mitte massiv
belastet während die die richtig viel
verdienen am Ende sogar noch mehr Geld
in ihrem Geldbeutel haben es müsste doch
gerade umgekehrt sein dafür setzen wir
uns
[Applaus]
ein und
ja ich denke wir müssen wirklich auch
noch einmal neu nachdenken und auch
darüber reden öffentlich auch in unserem
Land wie wir unser gesellschaftliches
Miteinander und in unsere Wirtschaft
gestalten wollen Märkte und Wettbewerb
die sind ein gutes Instrument um
Unternehmen zur Innovation Effizienz und
Kundenorientierung anzuhalten aber das
gilt nur da wo Wettbewerb wirklich fair
funktioniert wo einzelne Unternehmen so
groß sind dass sie Zulieferern und
Kunden ihre Preise diktieren können da
funktioniert es eben nicht oder da wo es
natürliche Monopole gibt wie bei den
Stromenergie und auch bei den bei den
Kommunikationsnetzen bei den gasnetzen
da funktioniert es nicht und wo es um
existentielle Bedürfnisse geht wie
wohnen Gesundheit oder Bildung da
setzten Kommerz und Rendite denken doch
völlig falsche Anreize und das sehen wir
am krassesten in unserem
Gesundheitssystem wir haben das zwei
teuerste Gesundheitswesen der Welt und
trotzdem wartet ein Kassenpatient Monate
auf einen Facharzttermin während es kein
anderes europäisches Land gibt wo so
viele Menschen an der Hüfte und am Knie
operiert werden das ist aber nicht so
weil wir ein Volk von hüftlahmen sind
sondern das ist so weil wir den
Krankenhäusern eingetrimmt haben nicht
zuerst zu fragen was braucht der Kranke
sondern was bringt das meiste Geld ein
Gesundheitssystem was so funktioniert
ist krank liebe Freundin und
[Applaus]
Freunde und wollen
wir
wollen wir wirklich in einer
Gesellschaft leben wo sich alles nur
noch darum dreht aus Geld mehr Geld zu
machen in der wenigen enorme Macht
eingeräumt wird sich zu lassen aller
anderen zu bereichern in der der
ehrliche immer häufiger der Dumme ist
hat der Mensch nicht etwas Besseres
verdient und ja auch Krieg Krieg ist für
die die über Kriege entscheiden anders
als für die die unter ihren Schrecken
leiden vor allem ein Geschäft da geht es
um Rohstoffe da geht es um
einflussphären da geht es immer auch um
Waffenverkäufe und ja auch hier sind wir
ja angeblich die guten wenn unsere
Außenministerin mit erhobenem
Zeigefinger durch die Welt reist und mal
eben beiläufig vielleicht auch Russland
den Krieg erklärt da tut sie das ja
immer im Namen einer
wertegeleiteten feministischen
Außenpolitik
so wie eins am Hindukusch wird ja heute
in der Ukraine unsere Freiheit
verteidigt und für unsere Freiheit
sollen die Ukrainer weiter leiden und
sterben und wir liefern Ihnen die Waffen
bis zum Sieg an den nur leider selbst
die ukrainischen Generäle nicht mehr
glauben ich finde das ist eine so
unverantwortliche
menschenverachtende Politik dieser Krieg
muss beendet
und war ganz schnell auf dem
Verhandlungsweg und das wäre möglich
wenn man es wirklich
[Applaus]
wollte und ganz nebenbei also das in dem
Land dass da heute angeblich so tapfer
unsere Freiheit und unsere Werte
verteidigt das in diesem Land ein NAZ
Kollaborateur wie Stepan bandera des
Milizen am Holocaust beteiligt waren der
für die Morde an tausenden Juden Russen
und Polen verantwortlich ist dass in
diesem Land ein solcher Mann als
Nationalheld verteidigt verehrt wird
nach demem Straßen und Plätze benannt
werden ich finde es schon seltsam dass
diese wirkliche rechtsoffenheit unsere
grünen Moralapostel
überhaupt nicht stört auch das zeigt die
Doppelmoral und Heuchelei ihrer Politik
aber
offenbar offenbar werden unsere Werte ja
inzwischen sogar in Saudi-Arabien
verteidigt immerhin will unsere
feministische
außenpolitikerin jetzt diesem Regime das
Frauen zu Tode steinigt das
Oppositionelle köpft und in dem auch mal
eben ein kritischer Journalist zersägt
wird ires Raketen und Eurofighter
liefern klar Raketen tragen immerhin den
weiblichen Namen Iris also so viel
Feminismus muss im Hause bärburg
offenbar
[Applaus]
sein na und wenn dann in den
rüstungsverträgen vielleicht sogar noch
gegendert wird dann ist die grüne Welt
offenbar wieder in Ordnung aber unsere
Welt ist nicht in Ordnung und deswegen
sagen wir Nein zu Krieg und Nein zu
waffenexorten in Kriegsgebiete das muss
gestoppt
werden und ich
denke ich denke schon um diesen Wahnsinn
zu stoppen dass das kriegstüchtige
Deutschland in einer Welt voller kriege
jetzt auch militärisch wieder ganz vorn
mitmischen will schon und das zu stoppen
war es so wichtig dass wir uns auf den
Weg gemacht haben und dass wir uns
weiter auf den Weg machen und dass ihr
alle dabei seid weil auch das ist unsere
Aufgabe dass diese Kriegspolitik aufhört
und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für
unsere neue Partei wo wir weiter uns
engagieren werden liebe Freundinnen und
[Applaus]
Freunde
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir haben
Großes vor für unser Land und für die
Menschen die große Erwartungen in uns
setzen wir sind es ihnen schuldig unsere
Sache gut zu machen danke
[Applaus]
schön